how often do people say six like I mean
all the time
doesn't bother me what up you cube this
is black and these are my essentials
[Music]
first up we have echinacea throat spray
just recently my vocal cords got
inflamed and I had like an infection in
the lost my voice towards the end of
Tours usually when I feel things start
to happen because it's like I'm pushing
to make it to the end so I had to
implement things to just keep all that
it's just healthy and perfect so I can
perform this actually tastes horrible
just imagine like a mixture between a
shot of alcohol and like motor oil that
is this right but it's worth it so if
you're a vocalist a singer or rapper or
you talk a lot echinacea throat spray is
amazing and you should get it
[Music]
this is Gucci Guilty black claw I feel
like this one fits me the most it's not
like super cologne II still kind of have
like a sweet smell to it not too
masculine not too feminine and yeah
bring it everywhere though I never
bought any cologne until I tried this on
and I was like like yeah that's the one
you buy the first time never switched
[Music]
thumbdrive I keep one on me just in case
you never know I might be enjoying my
regular day and I get a call like
somebody wants you to come to the studio
I make a song that I want to take home
with me instead of like waiting for
somebody to send me the song and it's
like no you can like put it right here
whatever I need I can slide it right on
here take it with me they aren't really
outdated to me yet
obviously there's so much more we can do
like airdrop but physical is still there
Lukie slides got a little scuffed up but
they get scuffed up because I pretty
much wear them like sneaky I didn't get
slides until until my first tour and I
didn't realize that they were essential
like I would see him all the time and be
like okay those are cool slides but I
didn't ever knew I needed them I didn't
wear so I thought until you're like
performing and you're running on stage
and you're walking and you're doing this
and you're doing that it's like sneakers
aren't always the most comfortable thing
to have one I was trying to think of
like a cool name for other than a brush
but this is a brush I had freeform
threads for a long time and had to cut
and reset got the little cut the dreads
just became something that I needed to
move past like when I was making free
black a lot of the music that I was
writing was me trying to get you know
past certain situations and the hair was
like it became my image so after a while
I just felt stagnant you know I felt
like I became the project I was trying
to like write myself out of so one day I
woke up and I was just like get rid of
there and start fresh this just ensures
that my hair doesn't grow up straight
like it used to the next thing that adds
onto the brush combo which is a shea
butter oil found it at the flea market
but this is the oil that I use for my
hair it's called mingle it's the only
thing I use otherwise my hair is gonna
be dry because I'm just not gonna put
anything else in it spray a couple get
the waves down you know do I'll add a
little water to the brush and then hit
all sides
[Music]
we have very little just small things I
don't like big jewelry I don't like
heavy jewelry so you just have like a
Cuban link ring little cross here gold
nugget ring leave the time rings on this
hand this one's kind of banged up at it
for a very long time
[Music]
Rolex very tuned this is my favorite one
I just got it it almost looks like
flowers
it was handcrafted 22 carats little
bracelets here I like gold as you can
see it elevates the outfit and like I
just saw myself like without all my
jewelry recently you know it's like
calling family
so therefore like another essential if
you wear a lot of black then you need a
lint roller I have a cat
I like cats I'm around pets a lot nine
times out of 10 when I'm going to put a
shirt on I'm just like doing something
that's just gonna be cat hair or like
lint somewhere all over me so keep these
before you walk out the house get a
clean one of those sometimes you have to
pad it that gets like the lint off
better I learned that from the stylist I
think I'm much to say about a lint
roller it rose when we got these Gucci
boots
I love the buckle on the front I had a
pair Saint Laurent support very a long
time and these were just like a good
switch for me I don't like too many
flashy like obvious things but I don't
know it was pretty good thing I was like
a cool little bead on the back I put
these on maybe a week ago and since the
album came out I haven't taken them off
because they just fit the mood of
everything that's going on which is like
alright you know numbers are rolling in
projections are rolling and everybody's
excited
I'm not taking these off I'm about to
walk in and scope with these on and you
know have some meetings have some
conversations
[Music]
bring the back this is a time back had
another bag before this but this is like
I guess my new purchase you know I wish
I had wheels but the one with the wheels
cost on mine too so I'm trying to like
be a little bit modest um topic I think
about my daughter when I make purchases
I'm like oh I could get the wheels right
now but I can also make sure she got
some of those yeah good bye great
leather looks really good in the airport
get a lot of compliments that's the
thing about like getting these kind of
bags to is your force to compress if you
want to travel in style if that makes
sense I was like an over-packer at first
and when you get it back like this it's
like okay what do I need versus think
all those the stuff that I'm bringing
all my essentials they all fit they're
pretty tiny
and it works out honorable mention
there's this is just a merge piece
Balenciaga what is six in the front of
it just drop this the other day by the
time people see this it might not be
available no more you might have to like
get it on a black market eBay or
something like that it's gonna go it's
gonna sell six lakh market
[Music]